bom dia a todos
eu queria agradecer à guto ea faculdade
por ter me chamado
eu sou um dos caras que está fazendo um
novo modelo de educação no brasil
isso não é uma afirmativa arrogante
pelo contrário é uma afirmativa muito
realista
então o que você vai ouvir nos próximos
18 minutos
é uma coisa que tem que te em que está e
quem está profundamente se você
professor se você tem doutorado se você
tem pois doc se você tem mestrado
esquece tudo que você tem aí para você
ouvir o que eu vou ver agora o brasil
não é mais o mesmo e você ainda não
entendeu isso você não entendeu
você vai entender agora algumas pessoas
que vão falar que hoje vamos falar desse
brasil que você não entende a calma isso
na bronca
esse é o chamado eu fui chamado a
verdade eu não tenho diploma tem diploma
de nada
eu sou bolsista dessa casa todo o
primeiro período a administração eu vou
contextualizar você sobre quem é esse
gordinho está aqui falando que esse
gordinho que fala tanto tão marrento que
chega falando essas coisas eu sou o
dinho eu tenho 39 anos eu sou nascida em
madureira
eu quase não assinam a gôndola do
mercadão de madureira porque eu nasci no
hospital municipal em frente ao mercadão
de madureira que o hospital especulando
pinheiros e minha mãe espirrasse ea cair
dentro do ângulo do mercado então já
nasce dentro da classe cedo na classe de
economistas quiserem na eu morei até os
17 anos eu morei em 21 bairros
diferentes
janeiro que meu pai coitado enfim é o
carro dele
meu pai tinha uma ordem de despejo na
vida meu pai meu pai não morava em lugar
nenhum como é de seis meses vivia de
venda aluguel teve uma vida difícil dura
como vendedor não conseguia tinha comida
em casa de vez não tinha então às vezes
eu chegava em casa tava minha mãe
fazendo as caixas é muito bem da imagem
da minha mãe fazendo as cachorras ano
colocando as roupas dentro da caixa que
ia se mudar
nisso eu morei madureira cascadura
cavalcanti abolição piedade encantado
ilha do governador
9 na aliança na zona oeste perto da vila
kennedy la numa favela vila aliança
eu morei muito lugar e aí nessa de andar
pela cidade num caminhão de mudança
eu fui fazendo o mapeamento da cidade
sempre morei na zona norte sempre morei
no subúrbio minha família família de
nordestino a gente ou não tinha dinheiro
ou no destino vem pra cá pso dest só
para trabalhar então nordestino não vai
à lapa o samba nos vá no parque união e
pergunte quanto lá no parque união foram
ao corcovado não tem a galera vai do
trabalho para casa da casa do trabalho e
da casa pra igreja minha família e
nordestina evangélica ea minha avó
evangélica
então ia da escola a igreja da igreja
pra escola depois havia escola igreja
sempre nunca mudou
nisso eu matei os bairros da zona norte
onde seu som suburbano
descobri que era um suburbano aos nove
anos de idade só eu moro desse lado caso
o rio não sei que a ipanema não sei que
aí copacabana
vejo na televisão mas isso não faz parte
da minha realidade sempre detran andar
de trem não tem carro no mundo que me
faz não tira o prazer de estar dentro de
um trem
mas é o deus de misericórdia é o trem
que eu peguei um dia desses eu peguei um
trem indo pra casa da supervia supervia
de deus abençoe
e era o trem todo fechado com ar
condicionado mas o ar condicionado não
funciona o bebê não estava um calor eu
sou ano nas pernas uma desgraça e cheio
mas não tem um carro que me tira o
prazer de estar ali na é porque tu ouvir
cada coisa engraçada no trem o que
aconteceu comigo foi que mudando de
bairro em bairro
eu entrava na escola não mexe no outro
estava na outra escola
eu nunca tive um coleguinha de ano
inteiro nas costas e teve coleguinha de
outro bairro corda coleguinha de outros
lugares e fiquei com o colega espanhol
dumont lugar e eu morei tanto lugar que
os mesmos e não lembro de mim mas eu
lembro deles não é verdade é só ele está
aí só é minha companheira ela foi comigo
há dias atrás
hannah augusto franco só num bairro de
morador de juros
alguns franco antonio diz a padre manoel
da nóbrega barão que então morei todas
as ruas daquele bairro se o google maps
tivesse me chamado a 10 anos até pra
começar o projeto
aquela área já estava resolvida porque
só nunca consultoria de uma hora
resolver o problema deles usava carro
nada de saber os detalhes de tudo ali
funciona mercearia ali tem uma placa de
roni
eu fui lá na rua onde eu morei quando
era criança eu encontrei todos os meus
vizinhos perguntei para um deles se
lembra de mim que era criança comigo não
lembro não se lembra da minha mãe
madalena a costurava que não lembro não
então eu não tenho um lugar percebe
mapeando a cidade indo de escola em
escola e tendo que aprender e aprender
os códigos de cada bairro do rio de
janeiro cada bairro tem um código que
acontece aqui em bom sucesso acontece no
méier que acontece no menu acontece no
campo da vila do joão dentro do complexo
da maré
são códigos diferentes é um povo
diferente
eu tive que aprendendo os códigos de
todo mundo eu comecei a entender o
dialeto suburbano e aí nessa eu entendi
que o aprendizado não é só o que tem na
escola
aprendi sozinho
ela só garoto aí novo paulo freire
gordinho com pirulito na boca dizendo o
aprendizado não é só que na escola eu
fui aprendendo que o aprendizado é como
tião rocha fala plural é eu com o outro
em cada lugar cada bairro que eu vou eu
aprendo com outras coisas com outras
pessoas
então a parte que eu mais gostava na
sala quando era criança quando as
professor de arte juntava as crianças
que elas criança tudo perturbada
querendo desenhar pintar tudo e eu lá no
meio liderando as crianças perturbada e
agente desenhava e pintava tudo faziam
anarquia e aquilo me dava muito mais
informação sobre quem eram os meus
colegas e eu a escola gosta de pintar
vermelho isso aqui gosta de usar rosa
que gosta de usar verde a educação ela
precisa ter um componente da mistura do
inesperado quando nego fala programa
conteúdo programático da angústia duas
coisas sair correndo canvas e conteúdo
programático cara que fala campo à
espera de mim ou então uma crise de um
avc um trote
todo o meu remédio pressão porque tipo
esse cara não tá entendendo e conteúdo
programático negócio que me angustia que
o conteúdo programático tem que ser um
um norte brother saca um negócio ali que
a gente vai fazer esses tantos caminhos
para chegar lá não
mas voltando eu aprendi muito indo de
lugar em lugar de escola em escola
por fim eu aprendi muito com a igreja
sabe minha mãe não tinha comida livro
ela trabalhava de caixa de mercado como
costureira não tinha dinheiro a comprar
um livro que na escola dizer que
comprará nível que as coisas me manda a
bíblia quer saber da minha vó eu comecei
a ler a bíblia não lhe interessa do
começo ao final do dia o que queria eu
queria pegar um pedaço lia a casa de
saco cheio daquele negócio lá voltava
ainda é que agora
não é agora que é o de jesus há qualquer
lei qualquer outra coisa e aí nessa eu
fui lendo a bíblia acabei lendo ela
todas as vinte vezes o que não é difícil
que um garoto que só tem uma bíblia e
não tem internet já tem 39 anos
não tem um jogo do atari meus colegas
tinha não tinha e não podia fazer muita
coisa que a casa de crente
naquela época então eu estava
politicamente correta que a igreja me
ensinou muito a igreja me ensinou a arte
da igreja tem música minha avó cantava
minha mãe cantava eu tinha que cantar na
igreja a gente pega pelo braço e bota lá
na frente
kant meu filho minha mãe é comigo lá
para duque de caxias no centro de
convenção evangélica de caxias
o corpo do pastor raimundo nobre de
almeida que era da assembléia de deus
assembléia de deus é um reter marvel tem
alguém da assembléia de deus e levantar
meu quero ver tem ninguém precisa tem um
olhou deus precisamos dar 100 2
a gente precisa da assembléia de deus
nosso meio que a assembléia de deus é
uma catarse maravilhosa
e aí todo mundo canta todo mundo faz a
festa e o aprendizado é isso aí então a
minha avó cantava uma música que é para
ensinar khan times na pegou na minha mão
e cantava músicas e repete
quantas vezes tem chorado aos pés do
senhor já viu isso
agora prontamente deus atende o teu
clamor que a gente aprende a cantar aí
ela pegava agora vocês vão desenhar a
história de noé a a arcam de bichinho
aquilo pra mim era era o curso de arte
da gávea
só que aquilo pra mim era quando eu
cantava tocava no ídolos
a igreja também é um coletivo de
aprendizado que eu quero dizer com isso
qualquer lugar onde existam pessoas aqui
agora se a gente se mistura a gente faz
aprendizado
o tempo passou eo meu primeiro trabalho
foi de porteiro
meu pai não tinha conexões não tinha
rede levou pela mão me pediu para
trabalhar o porteiro lá no sindicato dos
securitários fiquei lá abrindo porta e
limpando o chão com creolina que o povo
lhe nava de noite eu acordava às cinco
da manhã para limpar clã trabalho de
muita coisa entregador de quentinha
entregador de pizza vários alimentos eu
entreguei se você pedir alguma coisa
para comer entre 21 entre 99 até 2002
provavelmente um deles foi o que
entreguei e aí professor de música fez
muita vem de revista fez muita coisa um
dia eu fui entrar na maré para dar aula
de música e na maré eu nunca mais saiu
morava na rua outra favela chamada vila
aliança e entrei na maré para dar aula
de música para um grupo num coral dentro
da favela na vila de um coral não ficam
batendo lápis gostado da flag
eu espero que vocês vão cantar aí
fizemos um coral
eu fui me envolvendo a maré me envolvi
com as pessoas me envolvi com outros
problemas até que o afroreggae me chamou
fui próprio regra é uma ong trabalhei
com júnior e aí no afroreggae descobrir
nossa onda muito grande eu quero fazer
coisas na equipe que sejam menos
institucionais mas com pessoas
então eu não tenho um trabalho de matar
mas eu encontrei marcelo tas um dia
saindo lado do discurso do obama quando
obama veio aqui e ganhou um ingresso por
aí por causa da flec falar da sua mama a
yota estava só isso traz trabalha com
comunicação né
o trabalho também ajuda a montar uma
agência dentro da favela ajuda e fui lá
e me ajudou tudo me apresentou um monte
de gente
passaram se três anos agora fizemos três
anos e nós não somos só mais uma agência
de comunicação dentro
nós somos um conjunto de seis
iniciativas de inovação social chamado
cdh tenha da arma que trabalha com
comunicação comunitária e comunicação
criativa inclusive para agências de são
paulo a almap dm9 coletivo é um grande
estudo de design
a flag a cubo cc
trabalhamos de igual para igual viu
chegava a um mapa é uma das maiores
agências do país ia ser recebido pelo
mar por um diretor lá da gr dm
ela é o cara vinha todo bonitão e eu de
boné e tênis se ou da arma tem que
acreditar em alguém nessa gente abriu a
func o que foi uma parceria com a flag
que é um projeto de cultura aberto
voltado para a cultura funk carioca
com isso é bom cara de conseguir uma boa
visibilidade e entramos no universo do
funk como cultura que precisa ser
aprendida divulgado em geral a cadeia
produtiva até que esse processo todo
levou e que house é um processo um
projeto de construção de casas quase que
em 3d
então tive um prêmio ted global depois
abrimos um projeto que foi o resumo de
tudo o que eu faço hoje universidade da
correria que é esse barato aqui ó
eu fiz 200 camisas não tinha patrocínio
queria explicar o pessoal da favela do
subúrbio como se faz um negócio eu fiz
200 camisas vendidas 200 camisas e
paguei as aulas
o projeto foi reconhecido por colômbia
peru e mentir por stanford
mas no rio no rio ninguém conhecer em
são paulo todo mundo conhece no rio
ninguém conhece porque a gente não foi
na petrobras bater lá a gente foi na rua
além de camisa o primeiro cara que
compra o caminho está aqui hoje foi o
eduardo eduardo vai falar que mais tarde
o primeiro cidadão comprou uma camisa
nossa
trinta e nove reais e com dinheiro a
gente pagar os professores
passou o tempo a gente foi mobilizado
negócio da maré
hoje o sebrae reconhece a gente com uma
metodologia integralmente voltada para a
mobilização de empreendedores e de
tecnologia na base da pirâmide
a gente acabou de assinar um contrato
com o sebrae a gente vai fazer isso no
complexo da maré no complexo do alemão
mesmo quando eu fico olhando esse
negócio de cara eu nunca imaginei que
fosse está fazendo isso
a universidade a correria é o grande
espaço de aprendizado
a gente chama costureira a gente chama
comerciante a gente chama camelô e tenta
discutir com esses caras como eles
entendem um negócio
a gente fala pra esses caras que o
dinheiro não é um fim
o dinheiro é um meio a gente gravou um
vídeo explicando que quero dinheiro
quando eu pego com um negócio um
empreendedor da favela que é um cara que
não tem mais 30 anos é um cara que já
fracassou e tudo é auxiliar de serviços
gerais
e esse cara que ninguém acredita nele a
gente acreditar nele
acho que o principal potencial da
universal na correria e dizer para o
cara que ele pode fazer aquilo não é
explicar o campus o câmbio é um veículo
ea gente trato camas como um fim é uma
bobagem isso o ser humano é o fim
a gente chama aquela galera toda alguns
já vieram do tráfico explica como ele
monta um negócio e pergunta se quer
ganhar
eu quero ganhar 10 mil reais ao porquê
aí você ensina a tocar o valor do
dinheiro à universal da correria está
existindo eu não trouxe nada
eu fiz um teste x na maré que foi o
primeiro teste que teve uma favela
levamos vários aqui e vão fernando
henrique pra lá eu não trouxe nada
porque não consigo me organizar esse
ponto de falar e apertar um negócio aqui
mas se você procurar na internet você
vai achar a universidade a correria
a última coisa que eu queria dizer pra
unisuam preste atenção e é muito bonito
vem aqui falar de inovação e mudança e
tá aí vocês vão ouvir vocês não vão
fazer nada não vão porque não faz o que
tem que fazer
aqui tem um monte de parede branca na
sala de aula um monte de parede branca
isso não tem nada mais angustiante que
parede branca button mural cá de rolha
para os alunos irem na escrever e fazer
desenho mandar mensagem para turma dizer
que está vendendo alguma coisa
bota aqui ó no centro no pátio ou faz um
estande vizinho
o estande aberto para comércio aberto
dos alunos para eles aprenderem a viver
comunidade trazer aquele aluno que
precisa vender um bolo para pagar uma
passagem vender uma camisa
deixa eles colocam os produtos lá e um
pote encontrava lá paga tem isso na
unirio
porque aí aqueles aprender comunidade
aprende a ter honestidade
aprendi a ter ética o que é preciso
fazer não é investir no cara lá da
califórnia trazer esse cara pra cá a
gente olha para dentro
e você que é educador entra na sala de
aula só por causa do teu salário vem
trabalhar em qualquer outra coisa cara
entra na sala de aula o que você gosta
de estar ali se envolve com o aluno
aposta nesse cara a primeira aula dado
de qualquer período deve ser todo mundo
sentado em uma roda para se ouvir que
são seres humanos que vão vir com viver
quatro anos ele tem que se conhecer
volta para o simples volta o ser humano
para que essas bobagens
vamos encher essas peças parede branca
de mensagem de idéia
porque é a inovação está aí na mistura
esse quadro aqui ó
eu lembro que guto falou pra mim assim o
odin
vamos fazer um letreiro vamos a ele
procurou procurou procurou o letreiro
estava saindo por quase 17 mil reais o
segundo vai mandar na faculdade e vamos
procurar um negócio que você tem aí
vamos fazer um negócio aqui a r$0 está
aí ele ele catou um quadro fez essa arte
bonita o quadro tem tudo a ver com a
educação isso aqui foi feito na casa não
custou nada
a solução meu camarada tac
a solução está nas pessoas não tá lá
fora
agora eu posso pedir para vocês para
terminar um par de caló um par de gogó e
vamos a partir de amanhã depois desse
encontro fazer alguma coisa pela nossa
educação pela nossa comunidade
esse é o meu pedido e eu agradeço a
todos muito obrigado